- Love that you all
compliment each other there.
Congratulations on your Grammy!
- Thank you.
- That's unbelievable.
And y'all I don't,
had y'all met Idina before?
- No.
- No, we hadn't, but now we have.
- I'm so happy for you.
- We're all Broadway lovers here.
This is a great show, happenstance,
but so it's been a wild year for y'all.
So can you believe that
your Grammy winners?
Did you expect that with this album?
- Oh no, I mean this started
as a fun songwriting challenge on TikTok,
and we started writing
music when it blew up,
and the rest is kind of history.
So it was not something
we expected at all.
- I mean, even when we released the music,
like it was just the two of us,
and we had no expectations,
and there was no way, in our head
that this could be nominated.
- You know what's cool about that though,
is that you were doing
cuz you just loved it.
You were doing something that inspired you
and was created, you know, creative.
And I think that's the fundamental
of like what we all do.
So yeah, that's the base of it.
So you won best musical theater album
against people like Bob Dylan
and Andrew Lloyd Webber.
So did you, and did you meet them?
- Yeah. I mean like
even when you say that,
it doesn't sound real, it sounds
it's like they're all of our idols.
So like to even be on a list
next to them is just crazy.
But the day that we got
nominated was insane,
because we were literally hanging out
with Andrew Lloyd Weber
all day long in London,
and then we're having
high tea at the Drury Lane
- Hey fancy!
- While we were watching the nominations,
and then we were both nominated,
and it just, it feels like a fever dream.
It was like, how are we in London?
Just hanging out with Andrew Lloyd Weber?
- How is this happening?
- And you're in the same category.
Did you call him afterwards
and go, I mean, it's on?
(all laughing)
- I mean I know you're
Andrew Lloyd Webber,
but yeah, it's on.
- He is so supportive of young composers.
So we love him.
We love him.
- The talented, genuine artists are.
So Idina, what TV show would
you turn into a musical,
if you could?
- "Golden Girls".
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
- [Abigail] Oh, that's brilliant.
- [Emily] Oh my God.
- See, I thought we
were like the same age,
cuz mine was "Designing Women".
It's like, I just wanna hear
that Dixie Carter monologue
and like a song form.
That's amazing.
And you probably have never
seen either, so it's fine.
It's fine.
- I'm always trying to get roles
that I know I'm gonna grow in.
- You're putting it out there.
It's just, it's awesome.
So are you inspired?
Did y'all, here's my thing y'all,
season two Bridgerton.
I was like, go ahead and try.
It was so good.
Did you like it?
If you let me down right now,
if you let me down right now
- Don't think of us differently,
we haven't had a chance to watch it yet,
but we're gonna watch it together.
- She's gonna kick us off the show.
(audience laughing and clapping)
- Like what?
You just won an album for this thing.
Wait or won an album.
won a Grammy for this thing?
Wait, you I'm so jealous.
It's like you, you know,
haven't seen "Sixth Sense" yet.
- I know.
You know, we're so excited.
- I just watched that for
the first time, by the way
- Isn't it trippy?
- and I didn't know it
- Exactly, you don't know,
and then you're like,
- Have you seen pretty woman?
- No.
- What?
- Yeah, see? No.
- I've seen bits and pieces of it on TV,
but I've never watched
it all the way through.
- Really?
What about Rocky?
- Yes.
- No, let's get back
to season two, ladies.
Totally judging you,
and by the way I literally was like
I didn't think like I'm
not really judging you,
but I didn't think that it
was going to even compare
and I knew like I was like, oh
that brother was like,
I, and it was so good.
- Yeah, I know I've heard great things.
- [Kelly] It's on point.
- Actually we met Jonathan Bailey too.
- [Abigail] The day we
got nominated, in London.
- [Kelly] I know who he is.
- The day we got nominated, it was like,
- I gotta be honest with
you, in the first season
I was like Anthony, Shmanthony.
And then the second when I was like,
who is Duke Hastings?
Like Anthony is so good.
- [Emily] That's great.
- No, it's so great.
And I, the tension is great.
So looking forward to
that album, if you wanna,
- I mean, you never know.
- Yeah, odds are we will.
- [Kelly] Will it, I'm gonna will it.